says the most gorgeous woman in the
world she looks spectacular
want to look like Jennifer Lopez well
her hubby Ben Affleck makes it sound
easy the confession comes on the Drew
Barrymore show where Ben admits his
wife's eating habits might surprise us
do you have a cheat drawer in the house
because I feel like I'm I don't know I
like do you tell you something that's
going to upset you okay
Jennifer just eats whatever she wants
and whatever she wants Pizza cookies ice
cream everything I do love that I love
it yeah but
but part most
she works out according to Ben Jen makes
room for her indulgences by hitting the
gym hard I mean I work out too but I
don't magically appear to be 20 years
old you know what I mean with perfect
skin and the whole I'm she is a just uh
there's no taking away the work ethic
the work ethic is real the discipline is
very real but also the Superhuman thing
is real she says the most gorgeous woman
in the world she looks spectacular I've
never seen anything like it the triple
threat shows off her fighting shape in
the trailer for her upcoming Thriller
the mother Jen plays A Deadly Assassin
in the action-packed Netflix film out
May 12th I'm a killer
but I'm also a mother
and I will die protecting her of course
Ben is Jen's number one hype man we're
super happy what can I tell you earlier
this month he revealed he knows all of
Jen's music on the smartless podcast
with Sean Hayes Will Arnett and his air
co-star Jason Bateman here's this
incredible actress and this incredible
performer and then we're sitting in the
car you know and I'm humming along like
I will you know the radio and then a
professional singer goes aheads and
sings along and you kind of feel like
well that's embarrassing yeah you guys
should just zip it do you know all her
music don't lie I do know uh can you
sing all of her songs not to you not
only does Ben say he knows all Jen's
music he's inspired some of her songs
too like 2002's dear Ben
love you
you're perfect the two were dating at
the time got engaged but split in 2004.
we were about to get married it didn't
work out it was my first like adult
heartbreak the couple rekindled their
love in 2021 nearly 17 years after
calling off their wedding and now Jen is
set to release her ninth studio album
this is me now the follow-up to 2002's
this is me then which famously featured
that sweet track it's a beautiful moment
the new album will include a song titled
dear Ben part 2 which documents the
second act of their love story
the same way this is me then captured a
very special moment in time
this album also did the same thing
captured a very special moment in time
she's amazing it takes a big man not to
feel inadequate so whether Ben's giving
Jen props for her work ethic the work
ethic is real the discipline is very
real or her work wait what songs have
been written about you dear Ben and dear
Ben cartoon about me have been written
by the greatest I'm performer in the
history of the world Jennifer Lopez safe
to say he's her biggest fan
[Music]
thank you